hello i'm greg sadler and i would like
to invite you to stoicon 2022
which will be taking place on saturday
october 29th it's an online conference
that everybody can participate in either
through the zoom that we'll be setting
up or through the modern stoicism
youtube channel if you're not familiar
with stoicon it is the
world's largest gathering of stoics and
this is the tenth year of stoicons and
i'll also add of stoic week which will
be going on roughly the same time the
stoicons early on took place in london
and new york city
toronto athens in greece and then with
covid they went online and we realized
that we could make it so much more
accessible to so many more people by
keeping it as an online conference and
that is precisely what we are doing for
the third time this year so we've got a
lot of great talks and workshops lined
up i just want to go through the
schedule a little bit i won't be saying
which times there you can click the link
that's below and find out all of that so
we'll begin with some opening remarks by
myself and some of the other conference
organizers andy shaka philianov and by
john sellers joining us as well
and then we're going to have a talk by
my friend and colleague peter stan kuich
why reformed stoicism something he's
proposing
then we'll have uh stoicism around the
world panel which is going to be
particularly
interesting with uh representatives of
stoic communities all over uh henry
manampiring from indonesia aldo dinucci
from brazil kelly andreas rodriguez from
spain
sasha roehter
from
germany and logan wallingdom from
norway with greg lopez moderating then
we'll have another talk coming up by
brittany palette from pre-rational
instinct to rational care
and then we'll have the big plenary talk
we're really happy this year to have
christopher gill one of the founders of
modern stoicism stoic week stoicon still
heavily involved in all of what's going
on and he is going to be giving a talk
called care of oneself others in our
world can stoicism help us to hold these
together
then
after a short break we will have a
personal
storytelling workshop by catherine
cormilas called becoming hercules
finding your superpowers understanding
your role in life and choosing your life
path very interactive and should be a
lot of fun
following that we are going to have
lightning round talks that are
contributed by anybody who wants to do a
short
two to five minute pre-recorded talk to
send in to us we'll stitch them all
together and that will as always be very
stimulating then we'll have another talk
by rob coulter
theory practice and pepsis if you don't
know rob coulter he and massimo
pigliucci have a great stoic podcast
actually philosophy is a way of life
podcast that you might find interesting
and then we will be finishing up with
another panel and this one will be
authors of and editors actually too
of recent books on stoicism so we'll
have duff lambros donald robertson kevin
vost david fideller
nancy sherman and my co-editor of
stoicism today selected essays volumes
three and four leia goldrick will be
participating as well harold covley will
be moderating that and then after that
we're gonna it's the sort of like big
question mark we're gonna have an after
party and casual conversation with
people who want to hang around online
and do that so it's an entire day
of great talks workshops panels you can
pop in for as much as you'd like
it's going there's going to be breaks in
between one of the
really the only complaint that we had
last year where the breaks were not
quite as long as people would like and
the reason was because the conference
was so good
nobody wanted to step away from it for
even a minute so it's going to be just
as good this year i hope that you can
join us for this really
stimulating event it is sort of a
celebration of all things stoics with
great speakers and panels all sorts of
thought-provoking things and practices
and principles that you can take home
and start applying in your life today so
i hope that you'll join us put it on
your calendar october 29th and i'll
hopefully see you there i'm gonna be the
mc
so if you are there you'll see a little
bit of me and lots and lots of all of
these other
great speakers and scholars and
contributors and coaches having to do
with
stoicism and ancient philosophy in the
modern world